we need to get you out of here it's the  night before your wedding and you can't  spend the night together it's bad luck  we're grown adults we're fine no  actually you should go it's tradition  see she gets it I just want to ask is  that genetics or is it like Pilates  strands in your eyes they color them  wonderful we got you a gift it's just  something borrowed brings you good luck  except for Uncle Greg who ended up  decapitated on that forklift but that's  not the knives fault oh someone just  left it in the bathroom  we belong together look at you I think  the left Booth is slightly lower than  the right boom  [Music]  I feel right  [Applause]  Pirates  it's normal to feel scared remember  anything happen to your family I'm also  feeling scared like the most scared I've  ever been in my whole life it's like I  just watched the ring you know  bring him in the eyes  [Music]  nobody is with my family  [Music]  your sister  Carol thank you for the cake knife  [Music]